I have this theory that like I think
stories
I think we have a biological reaction to
stories in the same way that we have to
music
there's a reason why the Bible didn't
just say just do these things there's a
reason why they put them in story right
because it's far more impactful to to
listen to this story and I wonder if
like through osmosis the behavior in the
stories kind of get locked into our
long-term memory where if you just tell
someone a rule it's short term and it
might be fleeting well the the thing
about having the rule embodied in the
story is you see how it's acted out
that's much more convincing to watch how
something's acted out partly because
then you also know how to act it out
right if it's just a rule you have to
translate the rule into action but if
it's a story then the actions are laid
out for you
[Music]
thank you
hello to everyone who's watching and
listening on YouTube and on the podcast
platforms I'm speaking today with
comedian Andrew Schultz who's also an
actor producer and podcaster
one of the biggest and most influential
names in comedy today the business savvy
Schultz has been credited with helping
to spur democratization in comedy he has
proven that Comics looking to retain
ownership of their material by
self-releasing on platforms like YouTube
can achieve equal or greater success
both financially and in terms of the
building of an audience in comparison to
those who strike deals with streamers or
networks Schultz recently sold more than
150 000 tickets as part of his 10-month
sold out Infamous tour which he capped
off by selling out the 6 000 seat Radio
City Music Hall in New York twice
he premiered his subsequent special
infamous exclusively via the live
streaming social media platform moment
house in July before releasing it for
free on YouTube where you can watch it
as I did this morning while Schultz has
self-released multiple specials
including his first titled four four one
in 2017. he's also managed to find
Success Through more conventional
channels having created written
performed an executive produced The
four-part Comedy Special Schultz Saves
America for Netflix in 2020
the next project he's involved in as an
actor is Kenya barris's remake of the
classic Streetball comedy White Men
Can't Jump for 20th century Studios
which has him sharing the screen with
Laura Harrier
he will also appear in Netflix romantic
comedy you people Top Line by Eddie
Murphy that must be a thrill for him
Jonah Hill and Julia Louis Dreyfus which
Barris will direct from his and Hill's
script Schultz will then rejoin Barris
for MGM Sports comedy underdogs
alongside Snoop Dogg so there'll be a
lot of marijuana involved in that past
credits on the TV side include HBO's
crashing Prime videos Sneaky Pete and
ifc's benders
Schultz's podcast flagrant is listened
to by 2 million devout fans weekly he
also co-hosts brilliant idiots with
Charlemagne the God
looking forward to talking to Andrew I'm
ready I'm ready let's do it man all
right so my mom discovered you this week
so she's an absolutely huge fan and uh
she says hello and she would be furious
if I didn't say hello for her what's
your mom's name Cameron Sandra Cameron
Schultz aha well say hello to her for me
and I'm really impressed that it only
took her a week to become a huge fan
that's yeah it's always good to know
that someone's mom likes me
yeah
yeah so so tell me hey tell me about
your your YouTube special and and how
that came about you you decided not to
stream it you put it on YouTube instead
so yeah I want to know the whole story
how'd that come about
okay so short short version of the story
is I was uh I was originally gonna do it
with a streamer right and then they they
were unhappy with some jokes I think the
climate changed a little bit and they
were quite concerned how the jokes could
reflect on the brand which is
reasonable I think that like a private
Corporation has the right to make those
decisions for themselves and then uh you
know see how things go for them after
that now sometimes those decisions could
be the wrong ones you know you could
maybe become too woke in your content
and then end up losing money but
uh
[Applause]
to woke how could that possibly be too
woke for comedy I can't even imagine
that's a thing no but okay side note I
mean I want to get back to the special
but there is something interesting that
I've learned from like being in in
Hollywood a little bit more now is that
like I used to have the perception you
know I think we all create these
perceptions where it's like there's this
like group of organized individuals that
are like coming together and making
decisions on like what is palatable and
what isn't palatable and then inserting
those into culture in their like
different fields like Hollywood one of
them okay all the movies this year are
going to be about uh non-binary or
whatever it is
and after being in it a little bit more
I think that it's way less organized and
more about self-preservation
so it's like how do I not lose my job
big government continues to spend
borrowed money inflation continues to
swell dragging down our economy and the
stock market has entered bear territory
so what's your plan are your assets
Diversified I'm Phillip Patrick precious
metal specialist for the Birch gold
group for nearly 20 years we've helped
Americans diversify into gold and we can
help you too did you know you can own
physical gold and silver in a tax
sheltered account we can help you
transfer an IRA or 401K tied to stocks
into an IRA in Gold if you're skeptical
about the trajectory of the economy in
the US dollar then text Jordan to 989898
Birch gold group will send you a free
info kit on securing your savings with
gold with thousands of satisfied
customers five star reviews and an A
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau we take Precious Metals seriously
text Jordan to 989898 for your free info
kit
well I worked with middle managers for a
long time when I was selling
uh Personnel evaluation technology to
corporations and I did that for about 10
years rather unsuccessfully when we
found one company that used them
extensively but I learned very rapidly
there that the fundamental motivation of
virtually every middle manager in a
corporation is how could I not quit
blamed if something goes wrong yes
that's it man there's no there's no
ambition there's no desire to grow the
company there's nothing but I don't want
to stick out if there's a mistake I
don't want it to be on me I hope I don't
get blamed for anything I'm not going to
do anything dangerous ever and yes yeah
yeah yeah and the idea that people are
organized enough to have a conspiracy is
that that's just so rarely the case
but I was part of that belief a little
bit because you see it it looks so
obvious you're like why is every single
movie the same every single TV show the
same are they having the same values but
then after like I had a moment on a show
a while ago where a guy got fired a
white older man got fired because he
read the n-word like he read the script
and it had the n-word in it and like the
whole cast was kind of like the people I
spoke to on the cast even the black
people in the cast were like yeah I
don't I don't think it's that offensive
but the companies involved were thinking
what the middleman was thinking what you
just said which was okay I don't want to
be responsible for this how do we uh how
do I get this blame off of me okay maybe
if we just remove this person it'll be a
sign that we are we care about the
people that are here we don't want them
to be offended Etc now I don't think I
don't know I don't believe that the guy
did it out of malice and the black
people I spoke to on the cast were like
yeah I don't think he was being
malicious at all
um but it was one of those things where
everybody was fighting for
the the ability to continue working and
they didn't want to take that
responsibility and because of that they
made a very woke decision yeah so now it
may you know what I'm saying it made me
look at the industry a little
differently like everybody it's like
maybe the more desired the job is the
more willing the middle managers will be
to to to be extremely liberal in their
values so they don't lose that
opportunity I don't think that exists on
a construction site because the guy's
there like look I can get a job doing
drywall somewhere else so I'm gonna say
whatever the [ __ ] jokes I want to say on
this construction site
so I think too though there's there's a
complicating Factor there which is it's
something like this so
you know each of us carries a
representation of systems of ideas in
our in our imagination in our mind
and those ideas are active within us
that's one way of thinking about it and
nobody is a 100 percent repository of
all woke ideas yeah but so there's
fragments of the woke net of ideas in
any given individual but if you get 20
people who have fragments of those ideas
in their head all together in a room
then you have the whole goddamn woke
catastrophe operating right and then
it'll look like a conspiracy and then
you can take 20 different people each of
whom have fragments of the woke nonsense
in their head and put them in a
different room they'll come up with the
same decisions there are webs of ideas
that and in some sense each of us acts
as a neuron in a in a in a neural web
when we're together in a group and so
then things look conspiratorial but it's
a consequence of the working out of the
internal logic of systems of ideas and
so yeah and then it might be that each
individual actor is fundamentally only
concerned with not being held
accountable for ever making any kind of
mistake which is a hell of a way to live
your life certainly no way to live your
life if you're a comedian or a man for
that matter
maybe not even a woman you know not even
yeah yeah
it was just it was an interesting thing
for me to see how it kind of manifested
and I think that there is like an
opposite version of that because now
I've seen like the
the conservative woke
pop-up have you been are you familiar
with this or what are you referring to
I don't even know if I called the
conservative it's a really interesting
thing it's I would almost call it like
The Counter Culture Brigade which is
like people who I think have been I
think they were called conspiracy
theorists and now they're kind of like
searching for a home I think a lot of
the the support for Kanye even right now
is he's just tapping into very Niche
beliefs and a bunch of them at the same
time that people have no representation
for and now he's the most famous person
tapping into those those groups right so
he's like Jordan uh he's like um George
Floyd really died of Fentanyl and now
all the people that are anti-black
matter black lives matter they just
[ __ ] hate the idea that there's
anything else that killed him but his
own choice to do Fentanyl are like okay
Kanye's got it and
he also did a thing I saw you know the
Jews around the banks the Jews run all
these things so he's tapped into all
these Niche groups and now he's become
like their representative but what I've
noticed about these groups is that like
they're so scorned by maybe being lied
to by the mainstream Media or whatever
it is that their personality or identity
has almost become the rejection thereof
yeah well that's that's always a threat
that exists on the conservative side you
know the the left Wingers always accused
the conservatives of being reactionary
and they're reactionary because they
keep saying things like you guys on the
left you're going too far you've got to
slow down you've got to stop doing this
you're going too far and that is
reactionary in some sense because
they're always reacting to the excesses
of the left the the conservative types
tend not to want to change things and
you know that can be their downfall too
because sometimes things have to change
although intelligent conservatives sure
know that but um
it's hard for the conservatives to come
up with a vision and to unite themselves
because well first of all they tend to
stand for tradition it's not that easy
to articulate traditional norms and
second they do get reactionary and you
know that can turn into kind of a
demented populism too because the
reactionary conservatives can go out and
find the disaffected people on the right
and there's plenty of them now and then
capitalize on their resentment I mean
Trump was pretty good at that in many
ways
um yeah and continues to be so you know
um yeah and and that's I haven't been
targeted particularly by the right
although I have to some degree years ago
you know and yeah when when I first rose
to whatever degree of notoriety I have
now
a lot of the disaffected types on the
right we're also hoping that I'd be
their guy and same thing happened to Dan
Crenshaw the congressman because he kind
of looks he's got that evil right-wing
super villain appearance if if you you
know in some sense and they were kind of
hoping he'd be their man and he wasn't
and he actually gets targeted more by
the by the conspiratorial right than he
gets harassed by the left which is quite
the accomplishment on crenshaw's part
while today's cups of coffee often come
with hints of soy and social justice our
new coffee sponsor delivers an entirely
different experience it's bold strong
delicious and overall as good as the
causes it supports I'm speaking of
course about Black Rifle coffee many of
you know about Black Rifle already it's
a veteran founded and operated Coffee
Company who have made it their mission
to hire 10 000 veterans and they're well
on their way by purchasing for Black
Rifle Coffee Company you're directly
supporting the military service
Community but what about the coffee
itself well it's bold strong and really
good
go to Black riflecoffee.com and use
promo code Jordan for 10 off your first
order or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription the
subscription gives you free shipping on
all coffee Club orders Early Access to
Club deals and promotions and special
discounts from their partner Brands
that's black riflecoffee.com with promo
code Jordan for 10 off your first order
or when you sign up to become a coffee
Club member Black Rifle coffee
supporting veterans and America's coffee
[Music]
and he's a perfect example because
it's almost like this group of people
who have felt so rejected by everything
I'm talking about the extreme
conservatives we need another term for
it like I don't like how liberal and
conservative it's too um binary because
I don't even see like the yeah
right now good work good work Andrew
yeah you see you fell right into the
clutches of that system
they get me they get me yeah but
it's like
because I've seen the way that they went
after Crenshaw when he disagreed I think
about like gun rights or something like
that he was their Champion as long as he
said everything that they agree with and
the second he diverted from their
beliefs he no longer was useful and this
should happen this happened to me I
didn't even know that this like cluster
of people existed in this like organized
way but like I did a rant where I went
after Kanye and I thought it was kind of
a pretty easy thing to do here's a
billionaire that said some awful things
I'm going to roast them with jokes this
is what I do I think we can make fun of
billionaires I think they're okay to
make fun of and there was this like
onslaught of comments about people
saying you got it wrong you know it's
fentanyl it killed Jordan Floyd you got
it wrong the Jews do run the banks they
do these things and I'm like who what
what is this group of people and why are
they so organized and hateful why is
Kanye their new guy and I started dming
some people that were like trashing me
and I was just explain like what you're
upset about to me I don't understand
like we're just making fun of like a
really rich guy that said some awful
things and
the reaction that every single one of
them said was so funny they're like look
Kanye is an idiot but he's right about
these things and they're basically
saying anybody who agrees with me and is
famous I'm gonna ride for as long as
they agree with me and the second they
divert the problem with social media is
that you have to hear from people like
that you know let me tell you a story I
was talking to uh Andy no the journalist
who covers antifa
yeah and uh I had been talking to some
prominent Democrats about antifa and
they said it doesn't exist
and I said well what do you mean it
doesn't exist it
promoted riots in multiple American
cities there's people in Black masks and
uniforms that call themselves antifa
how do you mean it doesn't exist say
well there's hardly any of them they're
not really organized they're not an
official group
um and they're a tiny tiny they're such
a tiny minority that they're negligible
and uh I didn't really appear to me that
they were negligible but these were
respectable people and they weren't
stupid and I thought okay they probably
have a reason for thinking this so I
asked Andy no about this because he
knows more about antifa than anyone else
in the world and I said how many antifa
sales do you think there are cells so to
speak in the United States and he
thought well maybe 40 and I said well
how many full-time equivalent employees
do each of these cells have so to speak
right how many people in each City are
devoting them their lives to being
antifa whatever that means and he
figured 20. and so that's 800. out of
300 million it's one in four hundred
thousand
and so like that's none right in a city
the size of Halifax
City many Americans probably don't know
about but it's a city of about 400 000
in Canada you'd have one person and like
in some ways that's zero people right
it's just no one right but the problem
is is that a very tiny number of people
can cause a tremendous amount of
problems a tremendous amount of trouble
and maybe enough trouble to bring down a
whole civilization maybe it only takes
one in a hundred thousand to do that
especially if they're organized and now
with social media well they're always
organized because no matter how peculiar
you are you can find another 100 dimwits
exactly like you on the net and then you
start to think that well you've got
something there and you know in some
ways that's a plus because disaffected
people can find a community but man it
depends on who the disaffected people
are and exactly what the community is up
to
yes so and then you know you're in a
situation where you're putting out
content to hundreds of thousands or
millions of people and
you you also you get feedback but it's
demented and strange feedback because
it's not representative of the normal
population it's yeah it might be that
subset of people who had a really bad
day for reasons you don't even
understand and that are deciding to take
it out on you behind a mask of anonymity
there's something very pathological
about the democratization of public
discourse on social media it's really
warped and demented
now my my question to you is why do you
think that those Democrat leaders didn't
acknowledge that this was a problem do
you think they truly didn't think it was
a problem based on the data or do you
think that they were also acting in
terms of self-preservation well I think
for Chan and an inspiratorial
truly real
but that's self-preservation yeah I know
criticize the opposition it's not those
votes it's also justification for their
own beliefs
of course of course but like I I
actually admire what Crenshaw did is he
knew by taking that stand that he was
going to reject some of his base I
admire that that's a ballsy Brave move
stand up for something you believe in
despite pissing off people who may
follow you and support you
he's not acting in terms of
self-preservation he's doing what he
genuinely thinks the right thing to do
is now in politics this is middle
management right you have to support
your constituents if you want to stay in
office if you truly care about holding
on to power if you truly care about
making change you're going to piss off
your constituents by rejecting antifa
because the opposition is gonna or your
your maybe Democratic opposition is
going to position you as someone who is
not empathetic to the liberal plate yeah
well you know the the easy way out of
this as far as I can tell well easy the
only real way out of this conundrum is
just to say what you think like you
don't have to say everything you think
all the time but you have to you have to
decide at some point whether you're
going to Pander to the short-term
demands of your hypothetical
constituents or whether you're just
going to say what you believe to be true
and the thing is is that I watch
politicians and this is this is a
particular terrible thing that's
happening in the political Arena right
now is they use opinion polls to sample
the consequences of their actions but
most of that's just rubbish and the
reason I'm saying that there's technical
reasons for that is that if you want to
find out what people think
say even one person it's extremely
difficult because first of all people
don't know exactly what they think and
they can't articulate it that well and
it's a mystery even to them and so you
have to spend a lot of time listening to
find out what anybody thinks about
anything especially if you're not just
going to go for their immediate cliches
and then if you're going to sample a
whole population and try to get their
opinion about some political issue then
you have to formulate the questions with
unbelievable care it really takes
to find out what people think about any
given complex issue would probably take
a team of reasonable researchers two or
three months to formulate the questions
accurately enough to get a reasonable
response and yet opinion pollsters claim
that they can just tell you what people
think by coming up with some questions
and so then the politicians
judge the results of their actions by
the opinion polls which don't really
represent people's views at all and then
we're led by this idiot whim of the mob
and you know the real the real leaders
go out and listen to people
right and and then aggregate their
concerns and and then act on principle
and that's essentially what Crenshaw did
was and to tell the truth is to act on
principle and and I think with regard to
the medium to long term rather than the
short-term immediate you know popularity
payoff which is a bad way to it's a very
bad way to conduct your Affairs I don't
think it's a good long-term strategy
and imagine if you were a comedian and
you're you're your rule was I'll never
make a joke that offends anyone
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'd be I'd be a very different comedian
I'll tell you that yeah I think pretty
much every joke in your last special
would have been cut
yeah yeah yeah so back to that you said
the streaming service that you were
working with wanted to yeah they wanted
to edit your show and how in the hell
did they decide what was the hierarchy
of offense because I I watched your
special this morning and I thought every
goddamn thing you said was offensive so
how do they decide what to cut what to
keep
that's a great question you know I'm
sure that they have their everybody has
their like list list of what is right
and wrong and I think that list is so
malleable and I think that's for me
that's the most fun part of stand-up is
I like finding the divisive topic and
then seeing if there's like one kernel
that we can all agree on and sometimes
that thing that we all agree on is the
opposite of what everybody would like to
present themselves as
so like
like I'm trying to think of even I know
I had a bit about abortion in in the
special but I'm even thinking about like
abortion right now which is a very
divisive topic right I don't know how
you feel about it but I've been like
really thinking I'm like what is like
the the truth on how people feel about
abortion and I think I've gotten to it
which is
uh okay
everybody has a number of abortions
where if you go past that it's too many
so it's not really
even if you're liberal it's not really
your body your choice it's like your
body your choice up to like three
and then all of a sudden people are like
what's what's going on over here you
know nine nine is a softball team like
that's that's a lot right like that
usually people even the most liberal
person will be like all right we'll
teach her how to put on a condom or
something like what the [ __ ] is going on
over here and then the most conservative
person their number is one
they're like one is too many but we all
agree that there's a spectrum
of when it's too much and I think like
for me that's where a joke begins right
I go okay there's I can there's a whole
group of people in like this liberal San
Francisco audience where I may perform
at or a super liberal New York audience
what if I can get every person out even
the women that are super pro-choice to
be like yeah nine is a lot I you know
nine I think it might be the
government's choice at nine
you know like how can I get you to see
the other side without being a
politician about it going this is how
you must live your life how can I do it
we all laugh you know I think it was
like Oscar Wilde is like uh said like uh
if you want to tell uh some of the truth
make them laugh uh if not they'll kill
you and I don't think all comedy has to
be truthful and all that kind of I think
comedy speaks to feeling it doesn't
speak to what is right or wrong it
speaks to genuinely how you feel and um
it does tend to speak to truth in some
real sense because yeah when you laugh
when an audience laughs they laugh
spontaneously right
but the laughter is truthful because it
Taps into a feeling but just because you
feel a thing doesn't mean that that is
right or wrong and I think that's where
a lot of times comedians get in trouble
when they start going I'm speaking truth
to power I'm telling you what's right or
wrong and it's like buddy don't put the
cape on yeah just if you tell people
you're just out here telling jokes
you're just having fun now you're not
going to be positioned with the
responsibility to tell the truth every
time I want to tell [ __ ] up jokes I
want to say messed up things in order
for me to do that and have the freedom
to create in that space I can't be
Superman
you know I mean I can't say that I'm the
Arbiter of truth I'm going to get it
right every single time what I'm going
to do every single time is make you
laugh I think also that that actually
um what would you say it subordinates
comedy to something lower
you know when I you see this happening
with entertainers very frequently
probably most often with actors is but
sometimes with musicians sometimes with
other
let's call them entertainers it's a bad
term creative artists is they they get
possessed of the idea at some point that
what they're doing isn't good enough and
that because it isn't good enough they
have to do something truly good and
that's usually something in the
political Arena
and what they don't understand is that
there is almost nothing in the political
Arena that's anywhere near as good as
what works in the creative Arena so
you're immediately subordinating what's
best to what's lowest and so when you
see a Hollywood actor go on a political
Rampage you think well you're already
doing a lot of good for the world with
your creative actions and now you're now
you're a second-rate politician even
though you were a first-rate actor or
comedian or musician and you know I've
gone to a lot of artistic shows in
recent years and had them polluted by
political discussion and you get pulled
into the performance and then halfway
through there's something politically
correct often because that's generally
the case now and you think oh my God I
got suckered here you know I was coming
to hear someone great do something great
now I have to listen to the same
half-wit political opinion that I could
have not paid for and listened to any
undergraduate spout it's like well
thanks a lot for that you know you think
black lives matter well you know that
doesn't make you special
yeah you know anyone who's not an
outright bloody Nazi thinks that and so
it's just not it's just not elevating
and it's it's very sad thing to see that
um creative artists are buying the idea
part of this Rat's Nest of ideas we were
talking about earlier that uh
that politics is somehow morally
Superior political opinions are somehow
morally Superior to creative Endeavor
that's definitely the case on the comedy
front
yeah it's I wonder if it hmm
yeah I think it's hard I think like with
success and notoriety well it's twofold
it's like with extreme criticism for
example you went through extreme extreme
criticism it's hard I would imagine
to stick to your guns when you know that
you could easily back into the comfort
of the people supporting you right it's
the brave move is despite the criticism
continue saying and feeling uh but the
things that you feel for lack of a
better way to describe it but like to
continue being consistent on how you
feel and expressing that it's very easy
to get like this onslaught of criticism
from the left and then just go all right
the right likes me I'm gonna go right
wing all my opinions are conservative
Etc it's much harder to piss off the
left one day piss off the right the
other day because that's who you are as
a real person nobody is 100 in that way
and feeling that thought every single
time like what I what I try to I guess
Express in a lot of Comedy like I have
an abortion bit in the special to this
day nobody knows which side I am on the
abortion issue right and both sides
think that joke represents them that's
designed on purpose to do that like if
you even look at the comments both of
them are recognizing like the faults in
their side and also the support of their
side and to me it was really cool to put
out a piece like that that wasn't going
you're an idiot for not believing
exactly what I believe especially a
divisive topic like that I just think
it's I don't know like did you have that
moment where you were getting this
onslaught of criticism people are
calling you the next [ __ ] Nazi Diss
and then you're the The Muse for like
movie villains was there ever a moment
where you were like [ __ ] this I don't
need to stay true to myself let me back
into the comfort of the people who love
me
post-modernism is tearing our world
apart the one thing that may be able to
unite us is a mass return to Our
judeo-christian Roots at the individual
level that means developing our prayer
life there's a ton of literature out
there on the benefits of secular New Age
mindfulness meditation but what isn't
talked about nearly enough is the power
of a consistent prayer life that's where
hallow comes into play hallow is the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
U.S and the number one Catholic app in
the world hallow features over 5 000
prayers and meditations including daily
prayers to help you build a habit of
prayer and gratitude Bible reflections
with Jeff cavins and father Mike Schmitz
to help you grow in knowledge and
understanding meditations to help you
prepare for sleep and rest each day
reflections with Bishop Barron and much
more use hallow as a foundational tool
to grow in gratitude and character each
and every day try it free for three
months by going to hallow.com Jordan
that's hallow.com Jordan ground yourself
in fundamental truths with hallow today
yeah while it's hard to say you know
because a lot of that's pretty subtle if
all the attacks are almost all the
attacks are coming from one side and
almost all the support is coming from
the other side it also puts you in a
position of having to wonder just
exactly who your friends are
you know and one of the things I have
found is that for me for whatever reason
and I don't think that this is unique to
me it's a lot harder for me to talk to
people on the left
and the reason for that and it didn't
used to be like that not not 10 years
ago or 15 years ago
um yeah
in fact if you talked to me 15 years ago
I probably would have thought that I was
at least moderately on the left
and so but in any case I always feel
like I have to walk on eggshells I feel
like I have to watch what I'm saying and
I don't really like talking to people
around whom I have to watch what I'm
saying I actually like dark people and I
can just say what I have to say
especially if it happens to be funny
which now and then is the case and so
and then it is difficult not to identify
with people who support you especially
if that goes on for years
and so who knows how that changes you
know I I definitely have become more
conservative in my thinking and I would
say I think there are intellectual
reasons for that primarily though you
know because one of the things I've
understood
more deeply recently more explicitly you
know I've been putting this together is
that
the definition of Sanity that's
generally
implicitly held among the psychological
Community is probably too
individualistic
and what I mean by that is that I don't
think that sanity is something that you
have in your head it's not part of your
psyche it's not part of you exactly it's
more like harmonious interaction with
the hierarchy of social
um of social Arrangements that you have
with other people so well imagine this
for example i i a a neighbor I knew on
my street said to me once you're never
any happier than your most unhappy child
foreign
right so that's a good one but so you
imagine well you're a pretty sane person
and you're married and your marriage is
terrible it's like well then you're not
that sane are you and if you have a
terrible marriage and you're not getting
along with your kids then you're also
not very sane and if you're
if you're in a terrible marriage and you
don't get along with your kids and
you're fighting with your siblings and
your parents then you're even less sane
and
so imagine that sanity you're saying if
you have a relationship that's working
if you have a relationship with your
family that's working if that family is
nested inside a community that isn't too
fractious you know there's something
musical about it it's like every note
has its place and so I think yeah you
see what I mean and it's also I see yeah
I see what you mean but if I can give
some pushback I would say that like the
person that has the miserable marriage
and unhappy kids but is still seemingly
happy that person is insane to me the
person that has unhappy kids in an
unhappy marriage and is unhappy is sane
yes that's exactly well that's exactly
the point I'm making is that okay yes
because the thing is is that if you
aren't reflecting the structure of the
social communities around you then
you're off calibration well here I was
talking to a woman named Gene twangy
yesterday and she's a research
psychologist we were talking about
self-esteem
and one of the the self-esteem movement
in this school system in California was
absolutely dreadfully devastating and
appalling it basically posited that you
could teach kids how to be narcissistic
to overcome their negative emotion and
neuroticism and that's so preposterously
appalling that you couldn't invent
something stupider so we were talking
about self-esteem whatever the hell that
means because it's a very badly defined
term but here's one
way of determining whether you have the
appropriate amount of self-esteem you
might say well everyone should feel good
about themselves it's like well if
you're a miserable ratty lying deceptive
narcissistic prick then probably you
shouldn't feel that good about yourself
and how do you know that because you
should feel about as good about yourself
as people on average do around you about
you
right so you're and we even know this
technically because you have a little
counter so to speak yes in your psyche
that ranks you in terms of your social
standing
and the higher you're ranked the less
negative emotion you feel and the more
positive emotion you feel yeah yeah and
that's because your brain is indicating
to you that you're well situated in a
social community and you're secure with
opportunity and so your self-esteem
should that's exactly how it works it's
a very yeah so what happens to people
who get depressed
technically depressed is that that
counter goes astray and they start
thinking less of themselves then their
situation would indicate yeah and so
then everything around them falls apart
they feel that their past was a
catastrophe they feel that their present
is hopeless and that the future isn't
going anywhere but it's because this
really really low level counter that
utilizes serotonin has gone astray and
sometimes antidepressants can help deal
with that now that's not someone that
isn't someone who has a terrible life
that's someone who has a good life but
something's gone wrong with them
psychophysiologically often so the
counter is out of whack in any case you
should have about as much self-esteem as
other people are willing to Grant you
and that's kind of a conservative idea
as well in some real sense
enough self-esteem as others are willing
to Grant you yeah it's like well imagine
you know it
assume that you're an average performer
you shouldn't be running around feeling
good about yourself in excess of that
because your attitude towards yourself
should be a reflection of your actual
situation in the social environment
so my pushback on that would be
um if your self-esteem is defined by how
the people around you treat you how can
you break out yeah when you're in and
well especially when you're in an
industry of of narcissists that are
really only concerned with how they're
doing what they want like how how do you
separate yourself that that's a great
question man and that's that's the
that's the trick that that well presents
itself to everyone creative
but the answer maybe is
and this is I don't I don't know if we
support this but this might be the truth
there is a reason why narcissists tend
to break out because their self-esteem
is not limited by the views of others
that is that is true that is exactly
true well in fact in that regard so you
put your finger on something that's
cardally important because it is
generally the case that your view of
yourself should reflect the views of
those around you but the problem with
that is now and then the social
situation gets so pathological that
that's no longer reliable
now when that happens you're really in
trouble that's the first thing we should
point out because if Society has got so
demanded
that its feedback can no longer be
trusted then everything's that
everything's going to hell in a hand
basket pretty quickly but that is when
you get the necessity for people to call
on whatever it is within them that makes
them true moral agents to let's say say
what they believe to be true with with
great caution but I would say even in
those circumstances like I've been
fortunate when I've been doing that to
the degree I've been able to do that
because I have friends around me who are
giving me accurate feedback I would say
and careful feedback despite the mob
pressure I don't know if anybody could
really do that alone you know you know
what I mean maybe you've got 100 and 100
I just know and I'm sure you felt this
as well is it like
at least when I'm running my my business
and I have my my friends and the guys
that I work with and build with I
personally feel most creative when I
have support right so when there is a
momentum when the ball is moving when
there's an avalanche that's when these
explosions of creativity happen to me in
a conversation when I'm talking to
someone or other people who value what I
have to say all of a sudden I have tons
to say I'm excited to share when I'm
talking to someone who thinks that I'm
an idiot I'm questioning the things that
I have to say so in my mind I'm trying
to Foster an environment where everybody
here feels the confidence to access
their genius right now if they're genius
in one zone is a six that's fine if
their genus another zone is a 10 that's
fine but let me get the best version of
you now that's not saying we're
buttering people up yeah but at the same
time we're not treating it like I I
don't know I think like creativity is
not a football field right where it's
like you can only run as fast as you can
run I can yell at a player he's still
going to run a 40 in five seconds I can
say he sucks he's gonna run a 40 in five
seconds I can say he's great he's gonna
run 45 seconds but with somebody who's
coming up with like a creative idea a
funny idea the more I build his
confidence up the more willing he is to
go into those deep weird Concepts that
might produce something incredibly
creative yeah yeah well you do a lot
about by listening and attending right
and yeah and yeah because because people
people will
will manifest themselves more fully in
precise proportion to the degree that
they're being attended to and listening
to I was thinking too about the the
calibration issue you know one of the
values of a real education
is that you start to spread the
community that you identify with over
vast spans of time
so you know in in the humanities in
particular at least in principle there
was a golden thread of conversation
that's been going on at least from the
time of Socrates between great minds
moving forward that have been
adjudicated as great by the consensus of
the entire educated Community let's say
and now that's all of course parody does
as uh patriarchal oppression but we'll
leave that aside for the moment and then
maybe when when you're called upon to
speak carefully and truthfully despite
mob pressure and despite your
otherwise laudable willingness to
abide by the Judgment of the group The
Group starts to expand across time and
so the pathologies of the moment can be
ignored in favor of the
what would you call it the wisdom of the
group stretching across thousands and
thousands of years and you see that's
also in some sense a conservative idea
in in the deepest sense because the idea
would be that there is a fundamental
spiritual tradition that manifests
itself philosophically and theologically
that has to be attended to despite the
vagaries of the moment and so yeah and
that seems to be right you know I mean I
think what you do when if you go to
university and you get a real education
you find a peer group
the peer group of creative and truthful
thinkers and their thought in some sense
exists outside of time right it's
eternally valuable and it doesn't matter
what the situation is and then you can
judge your actions in the moment against
those standards
hmm
yeah but you're still picking the people
whose standards most resemble yours well
not necessarily not if you're really
getting educated you know because then
you get exposed to a lot of people who
didn't necessarily think the way you
thought
well this is this is why it's so
important it's like
and this is why the internet is amazing
but also dangerous it's just like
University in this way okay before the
internet there was college and that's
how I described it in high school you
talked to some people that had rough
experiences in high school especially
people are younger than me and I said
hey just wait to go to college you're
going to be dealing with way more people
and you'll be able to be yourself
because there's some other people that
actually feel just like you yeah right
and you're going to really like this
college experience because you're going
to find a friend group that just didn't
exist in your small 100 kid per grade uh
High School right
the internet is that on steroids right
now that little four-person group that
really likes gaming and wearing masks
and doing all this other [ __ ] is four
million globally you get to feel part of
a big group and you have all these
people that like what you have to say
but what I think that the internet can
often do and it's something that like I
try my hardest to not let it do is it
dulls our sword
you know what we don't have to
communicate outside of the echo chamber
right we know if we want we can say the
things we believe to the people who also
believe them and now there's no more
Nuance one of the great things about
getting on stage and doing stand-up
comedy show when people don't know I'm
going to be there right I've been very
fortunate to go and sell out from the
biggest theaters in in the country right
this has been awesome but one of the
really cool things about going up to a
show where people don't know I'm going
to be there is there people who may
disagree with me hate me not know me and
also love me all in the same room
and it keeps my tongue Sharp
I have to communicate to those people
ideas that they might disagree with in a
way that's funny enough for them to
listen and then project laughter
I fear
and I sometimes fear that like you've
experienced so much [ __ ] undeserved
hate from the left
that it's positioned you as with some
resentment which is reasonable I don't
know how you're even still having like
the common debate and discourse like if
most people in your situation they would
just say damn screw them whatever but
your information is more important to
the people who don't agree with you than
the ones who already agree
you know what I'm saying like yeah
explaining the value of let's say God
I'm not someone who's raised with
religion but I believe in the power of
it and so explaining the power of God to
someone who is not religious is more
important to the than to the believer
because if that person can get something
from it it's so powerful but if you've
only ever explained it to your
congregation you're not going to be able
to communicate it to me or another
person or a person who is a maybe
there's even an atheist there's no way
they're going to be able to digest it
yeah well that was that was part of the
potential danger of joining forces with
the daily wire you know because they're
obviously a conservative Enterprise and
my family and I thought long and hard
about that I mean first of all
um I like working with the daily wire
they've been extremely good to work with
they've left me alone
not only have they left me alone to do
whatever it is that I want to do they've
helped me do things I wanted to do that
I wouldn't have been able to do
otherwise and I also felt that it was
appropriate and wise to find some
um allies on the social media front
because well I got banned off Twitter
and you know YouTube hasn't harassed me
much although they've demonetized my
daughter several times for reasons that
are completely opaque and God only knows
you know what might happen on the
YouTube front I know they've demonetized
you on me Park many times the North
Korean dissident and that's because the
Army Park objects to North Korea you
know when you think you'd be able to get
away with that given that it's right
after all North Korea which is like the
worst dictatorship anyone's ever managed
to produce which is really saying
something right because there's been
some pretty bad dictatorships and so and
obviously the daily wire is a
conservative Enterprise and I was
worried that that would compromise my
ability to communicate with the very
people that you were just discussing
especially about the things that I want
to talk about but
um
you know also I would say
I don't exactly know what to make of
this you also find your friends where
they're willing to have you
you know and I get pilloried quite often
for not talking to enough people on the
left and a huge part of the reason for
that is that most of the time they won't
talk to me I I spent years trying to
find Democrats who would speak to me you
know actual politicians who would speak
to me on my YouTube channel and although
I have a couple identified now and
potentially lined up for years the
answer to that request was there's no
way we're going on your Channel
and so you know how the hell can you
talk to people if they just say no why
should they why should they go on their
Channel you're going to lobotomize them
like I don't think the answer is
speaking to politicians like I remember
I remember
first engaging like with your content
and what I think is so powerful about
you
is that you're such a thoughtful thinker
that you can really almost have I don't
want to use the word weaponized but like
you can weaponize Arguments for the
average person that has feelings they
can't articulate and I think what's
what's so powerful about that is that
you're giving a voice to someone that
doesn't feel confident enough to express
themselves right and it's a really but
what's really great about it is that
it's articulated in a way in which the
other side understands and accepts and I
think it's one of the reasons I was
probably drawn to you is because I like
doing this with comedy regardless of
which side I'm fighting for I would
never take a political side because
that's that's my ability to dance yeah I
can't dance once I say I'm on one I
don't want you to know where the joke is
going but what I loved is you you
deliver this information and it was so
hard to refute it and I don't care
whether you're on the daily wire or
whether you're on CNN Plus or whatever
that [ __ ] is doesn't matter to me
because as long as your thoughts stay
true to you then that will be
communicated maybe less people on the
left will digest them because you're on
the daily wire and that's their [ __ ]
bias which is stupid but I do want your
ideas to get to them and I want them to
get to them in a way where it's it's not
coming with resentment because nobody
listens once they're told they're an
idiot first you know what I mean like if
you're gonna listen you an idiot here's
why you're a [ __ ] idiot I already
shut down
you know what I'm saying like because
you said you want to fight me you didn't
you want to teach me something and I
wonder if when you were teaching in the
University level you were almost you
were almost it was like the comedy club
with the strangers you don't know who
these kids are where they're from well
it was awesome it was never political
you know I mean none of the things I did
at the University
until I objected to some Canadian
legislation wherever political yeah and
um I I didn't really expect politics
ruins everything I wish we could just
talk about it culturally like I don't
know politics creates this divide and
there are these people that it's just
like we were talking about before
they're just trying to preserve
themselves they just want to keep their
job they want to win their next
re-election and they're using you in
some gotcha strategy and I hated seeing
it happen but there's certain Realms
that once you enter you deal with the
onslaught there's like institutions like
you with banking you banking people are
going to take you out you politics
people are going to take you out and
there's probably like another one as
well and but for me it's like what are
these cultural conversations like it's
important the messaging that you get
across and I know it and you do
something and I'm not trying to
compliment myself here I'm just
complimenting you but like for me when
you express a a Viewpoint or a feeling
and my 75 year old mother likes it and a
19 year year old kid likes it you're
speaking to
core Primal human instinct
okay that is what jokes do if I see yeah
when I see generations of people at one
of my shows when I see a father and his
son both laughing together like one I
get emotional almost because I'm like oh
I love those moments with my Dad yeah
but two I'm like I'm hitting [ __ ]
core I'm hitting who you are I'm not
tapping into this like Community you're
supposed to be a part of I'm tapping
into something Primal yeah well so you
know you talked about people's ability
to find community on online and and the
analogy between that and the colleges I
think the difference is is that when you
go to college and you find people who
have your intellectual and creative
interests let's say you also do that
under the tutelage of older people so
there's an apprenticeship element and
you do it while you're being introduced
to the great thinkers of the past and so
there's a again that's a conservative
idea in some sense it's like you get
this new freedom and you get to you get
to expose yourself so to speak to new
people and but you do that within the
confines of an intellectual tradition
and so that stops IT from going
seriously sideways let's say into the
realm of ideology or propaganda or
conspiratorial thinking which are yeah
which are pathologies that you might
associate with that emergent group
identity and a lot of that's lacking
online obviously obviously yeah I hate
how I'll be honest like I hate how the
right has been bastardized I hate how
the left has been turned into like a
bunch of like [ __ ] little [ __ ] like I
think that there's these extreme
versions right like the extreme right is
not like a Romney conservative you know
what I mean like the extreme left is not
like uh I mean Clinton is you know
embroiled in controversy obviously but
like when my parents were growing up and
they were like Clinton Democrats you
know or even Obama if you want to say it
like these things are so close yet the
parties are are defined by their
extremes it's almost like soccer clubs
you know when you look at like these
soccer teams they're like defined by
their Hooligans a lot of times it's like
the hooligans are five not even five
percent of the people even go to the
games right so what I would love is the
discourse to come back here yeah well
and part of that part of that I really
think I was talking again to this Gene
twangy the other day about what's
happening online to facilitate that and
this tiny percentage of of of Bad actors
goes without punishment online
and that's a huge problem you know if
you're a real trouble making prick in
person someone's going to give you a
SWAT
and that's going to keep you down you
know and sometimes that doesn't happen
appropriately and sometimes it does but
generally speaking people watch their
tongues pretty carefully when they're
talking face to face with actual others
and the narcissists and the
machiavellians and the Psychopaths
keep themselves pretty well in check
because of that pressure but online none
of those
sanctions exist plus the social media
companies capitalize on the agitation
they produce and they literally
capitalize on it because their
algorithms Drive people's attention
towards the polarizing influences and so
yeah we're in a situation now where that
three percent because it's probably no
more than that
holds disproportionate influence over
over political discourse online and I
have the suspicion that that's tearing
us that's really tearing us apart
because it's yeah it's obliviating the
middle right the reasonable middle yeah
it's also the case I think that the
people in the reasonable middle
because they're reasonable and because
they're just going about their lives
aren't that good at articulating the
values of the middle right yes because
yeah I always think about this in
relationship to marriage it's like you
know some radical can come up to you and
poke you and say justify marriage and
the typical person is just going to be
set back on their heels it's like well I
don't know how to do that we agreed 50
000 years ago that marriage was a good
thing I can't come up with a
philosophical justification for it why
do you love your children
yeah well I don't know I just
yeah well it's it's the the you know the
the the the ideas that bind us that are
deep
they don't they're not generally they're
not generally articulated
and so when they're challenged those who
hold them have no idea what to say and
like here's another here's another
example I like to use this on people who
are radically left it's like why is
slavery wrong
how do you think well God it's obvious
that slavery is wrong slavery's just
wrong it's like okay fair enough why
yeah
well as far as I can tell it has to do
something it has to do with the
fundamental sanctity of the individual
it's basically a religious claim
yeah you're removing their freedom yeah
and their freedom is their freedom is an
appropriate part of them because they're
a part of Divine Providence it's
something like that that's the axiomatic
claim well if you dispense with the
entire religious underlay which is
really what you do if you're if you're
on the radical left it's like well then
why not why not just use power if I can
make you do what I want you to do
why the hell no let's do it
this is how jokes works like yeah but
why is it wrong because this is how
jokes work isn't this beautiful it's
like you find a way to get a person who
is an atheist doesn't believe in
religion thinks religion is the worst
thing in the world to agree that
religion has immense value by getting
them by getting them to agree that a
thing they hate slavery is wrong and
then you attach why slavery is wrong to
the thing that they also think is wrong
and now they have to choose one or the
other and that's not a hard Choice
religion why did you just
compare that to a joke I think you're
right but why why did that connection
occur for you because you're making
people choose what well for me that's
how I would enter anything I would go
okay
how there's a person who is not
religious
or we could even use like uh wait this
person is not religious I would like to
convince that person that religion is
valuable right so and I have bits that
I've done about this right so what do
they hold true what are their other
values maybe they're very liberal maybe
they don't believe in I mean I don't
think you have to be liberal to not
believe in slavery we should all not
believe in slavery but here's another
thing that they would hold true they
disagree with slavery okay now if I
believe that the reason why man has the
right to their their I guess
Independence and their freedom is
because I'm a God made individual and
God would never make somebody chained
uh then that person has to accept that
God is the reason why slavery is wrong
and therefore has to right right okay so
there is some okay there is something
there's something definitely there
because a punch line so there's a
there's a whole line of psychological we
need a punchline still yeah we need a
punchline still but that's a premise
right yeah right but the punch line is
what drives it home
you know and one of the things that I
have found I think that what I do on
stage is most analogous to what stand-up
comedians do and the reason for that is
that when I do a lecture for example or
try to answer a question yeah there's
usually an investigation but it has to
build up to a punch line there has to be
yes a culminating moment where it's
driven home and that's a moment of
insight and what it does is it takes a
bunch of information that's sort of
being scattered around and brings it
together and everybody goes Aha and
that's very much like the the the the
climax of a joke and it's yes it's part
of insight and so there's a
psychological literature on insight and
insight seems to develop when a number
of things that weren't linked together
are suddenly linked together and you go
aha that's how all that fits together
and I mean comedians are doing that all
the time because they they were
explaining the world and sometimes we're
explaining the world in ways that don't
really makes sense but they're funny
connections you know I had a one of the
earlier jokes in my career that worked
was uh you know we were talking a lot
about like the oppression of women and
I'm like okay maybe it'd be funny if I
could find a justification for the
oppression of women so I said you know
the oppression of women is horrible you
know countries that treat women horrible
I mean that's just awful but they have
the best food
so my Justified like you know nobody's
ever said you know let's go out for a
Canadian tonight right so to me that's
that's like the more equal country the
worst the food is and then the more
press of the country the better like I
think one of the lines was uh the more
countries like stay in the kitchen the
better the food comes out of the kitchen
you know now these are absurd Concepts
but a really funny connectivity right
right I'm justifying something awful but
now all of a sudden everybody in the
room is kind of agreeing like holy [ __ ]
like yeah I'm not a fan of Swedish food
I'm not a fan of you know I'm I've
really I really love hummus
Norwegians eat fermented shark
Jesus that's an argument this is what's
the equality of women right there
fermented sharks and that's just not a
good idea so yeah so this is the cans of
that stuff I think it's called Sir
strumming you can't fly on airplanes
with cans of that because they explode
so that is not a food you should eat so
to me now I don't have the
responsibility you have which is to be
truthful and right so I can dabble in
the wrong and the wrong is so funny but
for me like I don't know I I just love
this I love the wrong the rug is great
and we allow it allows us to explore
ideas like I got a boxing coach right
and uh not not for anything else other
than exercise I just love to do the
sport right but um and he's from Egypt
and he was speaking me in Egyptian
Arabic and I thought that like curse
words are a great way of organizing a
society's hierarchy in values like the
different curse words that they use
right and he was telling me he'll call
me different curse words he called me uh
MIT Naka right which means prostitute
sorry sorry Naka means um a [ __ ]
actually for lack of a better word
uh and then he goes uh charmuta he calls
me which means prostitute he goes now
listen outside of here don't say mitnaka
to anybody that is a horrible word okay
you cannot say that do not he's
basically don't call anybody a [ __ ] he
goes you can call people sharmuta that's
not that bad I go wait wait you're
saying [ __ ] is worse than prostitute and
he goes well you sometimes you have to
for money that makes sense but just
[ __ ] for pleasure what is wrong with
you go [ __ ] your boyfriend or something
and I thought it was like such a
beautiful look into culture
you know what I'm saying like like there
are dire circumstances that made it more
reasonable to have sex for money because
you needed money to survive maybe you
need to help your family and that was
forgiven culturally
in this it was it was like understood it
was like you don't want to do that but
at least you're doing it to support your
family yeah well just curling around the
curse words always touch on taboos right
and so taboos would be the worst thing
in a society
um the in in in Quebec all the curse
words are Church related
yeah exactly how do you know that why do
you know that it's my job to know these
things
so let me ask you again about your
special so it was going to be edited did
you know how heavily it was going to be
edited yeah they told me certain jokes
that they that they didn't like and
again I don't necessarily have
resentment yeah for companies that are
trying to protect themselves I you have
that right as a company I disagree
because I don't think it is the
protection that you want I think the
ultimate protection is putting out great
content well I love right exactly yeah
that's how you develop the moat but I
think it's very easy to just go like
[ __ ] you guys you guys want to censor
blah blah it's like yeah I get it you
have a family you have kids in private
school you don't want that maybe
responsibility of putting out the thing
that got your company in trouble yada
yada
so I don't have personal resentment it
was frustrating
so basically long story short what I did
is uh I bought the special back I and I
they could have said no to this but I
was able to buy the special back which
is I'm very grateful for and I put it up
on uh my own I put it up on moment
moment is this platform where you can
you know stream content so basically pay
for people to buy a ticket to watch the
show and then own it in perpetuity so I
first did a window there kind of like a
movie right like you go see Batman in
the movie theater that's how I was
thinking about it you go see Batman and
movie theater it's there in a movie
theater for a couple months and then a
few months after that it's on cable so I
was like let me try this for comedy I
put it up here and you know fingers
crossed and it does unbelievably well
and I made way more than I would ever
make on the special itself it was the
most money I've ever made in my life to
be honest with you and that was moment
it was on with moment yeah so like
moment uh yeah moment world is now but
it was moment house when I did it but
it's just great company they've been
doing these live stream events they do
it for bands they do it for Comedians
and I'm hoping that this is another
pathway for Comics to put their content
out and have a window where they can
monetize it I mean the beautiful thing
about putting your stuff out on YouTube
is it goes to the world but you're not
able to monetize it in the same way and
in order to create a special like the
one that we created I mean it costs 400
000 to shoot the specials so right you
have to be able to generate money to do
something that can compete with a a
Netflix compete with any of these other
and HBO any of these platforms I want to
be able to create that content and put
it out there so we put it behind this
window and people came out they
supported it was amazing and then a few
months later I put it out on YouTube
yeah and
that I think we're at eight million
views in a month or something like that
so now I get all the new people all the
people who aren't familiar with me all
the people that didn't know who I
existed and the friends can share it but
I was also able to give it to the to the
the fans who really have rode for me
from the beginning and give them this
experience also the YouTube version I
put uh some ads in yeah yeah yeah
rewards to watch this morning well what
did you charge for the special on moment
uh 15 bucks and how long did you have it
up there before you switched it to
YouTube
I did two two-week windows so I just did
two weeks and then so many people are
asking for it that I put it back up for
another two weeks a week later and why
did you decide
I don't know in periods
I wanted to create urgency I think I
think one of the issues with just having
you know like it up is I'll get to it I
think that's one of the problems with
content in general like I think
yeah I think I think uh you know there's
this idea with its streaming you're oh
I'll get to it I'll get to it and then
you never get to it and there's just so
much that you have to get to and I think
that if you create urgency like a boxing
match is we have to watch this tonight
an MMA fight we have to watch as a
sporting event we have to so knowing
that there's this two-week window where
you could watch it with no ads and this
was the way it was going to be you know
also there was no telling when I put it
on YouTube if they weren't going to take
it down so like this was the only time
that you were 100 sure that you could
watch it in its entirety and um it also
created this time where like everybody
well not everybody but a lot of people
watched it at the same time right right
so we had a live viewing and it created
this communal feeling which we want like
I love watching House of dragons you
know the Game of Thrones uh reboot uh I
love watching on Sunday with everybody
else and then going on Twitter and
seeing how people are reacting to it and
taking part in this massive group
experiment and hearing their live
real-time reactions to me this is
awesome so I wanted to create that for a
comedy special and um it was awesome we
were able to do it man yeah yeah yeah
well I'll have to look into moment that
sounds extremely interesting and then
you connect two with them okay okay you
doing you doing one of your lectures for
example on moment like creating this
moment having this moment for all these
people to all check in at the exact same
time and they've got some other really
cool features too like you can sell
merch while you're watching it like
there are all these different things
that are like easy to to access people
can comment real time on it which is
also so cool but like having this place
where all these people who want to
experience this thing with you be it
live or pre-recorded but before it goes
out to the world and people want to
support that's another thing I learned
like I've given out so many hours of
Comedy I've given there's so many people
that hit me up and they're like listen
like you've made me laugh with really
through really dark times for years like
there are people when I put it up on
YouTube started donating money I didn't
even know that that was a thing that you
could do but they felt guilty that they
didn't buy it
people don't people don't really want
something valuable for nothing they want
to contribute their part generally
speaking that's that's why giving away
things for free in some real sense is a
bad pricing decision
and so because it does it does deprive
people of the opportunity to reciprocate
and they want to be able to reciprocate
yeah so now you're having I think more
success on the movie front that's
correct
yeah I've been able to do uh some small
roles in some films and um I guess those
are all going to come out I don't even
know when they're going to come out but
uh I want to make a film
so
yeah to be honest
it's yeah well I guess I don't know here
here's I want to make a film I'm really
excited but I'm really getting into
story now and the power of story and
I know I have this theory that like I
think stories
I think we have a biological reaction to
stories in the same way that we have to
music
you know like yeah like I notice when
I'm hanging out with my friends that
I've known for decades we will retell
the same stories that we were all a part
of and every single time our our eyes
light up and we get goosebumps and we
laugh and we get excited and the story's
morph and change and we get to like
relive them in the same way when a song
comes on that was a song you absolutely
loved or you were going through
something you get to feel all those like
emotions again like you tap two towards
them and like even when somebody tells a
story in a group it's different than
when someone has like a hot take or a
premise it's like hey this thing
happened everybody shuts up and all of a
sudden we're like around the campfire
for some reason yeah so I'm I'm one I'm
curious your take on what that is about
us and story is it like our earliest
version of digesting information well I
think I think we this I'm writing a new
book called we who wrestle with God and
that's really what it's about um uh it
looks to me like
I think it's incontrovertible in some
sense that we see the world through a
story
and so if you're out with your friends
and you're telling a shared story then
you're you're literally building the
you're literally building the shared set
of assumptions that constitutes the
friendships
and so so think about the think about
the leftist Take On The World so the
leftist take is something like the
fundamental story is one of power and
the relationships between people are
structured as a consequence of power
that's true for marriages it's true for
history it's true for the Western Canon
it's true for economic interactions it's
all about power
well that's a story and it's not a very
good story by the way and it's also not
a story that unites or reflects reality
in an accurate manner because
social relationships are only predicated
on power when they become corrupt
so well if you have to force someone to
be your friend
that's just not working very well if you
have to force your wife to pay attention
to you then the bloody situation is
degenerated if you have to force your
children to listen all the time then
you're not mutually acting out a very
good story
and so the question is what's the story
that's the antithesis of power
and I think the antithesis of power is
play
hmm if you're if you're ensconced in a
good story then what you're doing is
playing this is one of the reasons it's
I really like watching comedians because
they're playing all the time and I think
you I think that play the spirit of play
is actually the antithesis of the spirit
of power let me tell you something that
will prove your theory and I have to
give credit to my uh podcast uh co-host
and uh just creative partner and so many
things about Mark Gagnon but we I took
him to uh this thing called Burning Man
this past year and his reflection on
burning man was he goes it's just adult
play I go what do you mean he goes think
about the whole thing is adult play now
to tap into the power thing Burning Man
is what happens when you remove power
there's no currency you cannot buy
anything and there's no restriction in
terms of your ability to enter once
you're there every party is welcome to
everybody every place is welcome to
everybody you can't even buy things you
just give so you remove traditional
power structure and hierarchy what is
left for humans
play dress how you want to dress dance
how you want to [ __ ] dance party How
You Wanna Party be silly prank one
another but play is the absence of power
wow that's kind of cool well look look
at well look at what happened I used to
go work out with a couple of my friends
in in Boston and uh we used to try to
make each other laugh when we were bench
pressing because as soon as you laugh
you lose all your muscular control and
so it's obvious that play and humor are
antithetical to power because as soon as
you laugh you're powerless you click uh
you you I think I I think I talked to
Theo Vaughn about this the comedian his
mother had a very strange condition if
he made her laugh she would actually
fall asleep
yeah she'd lose so much muscular control
that she would fall asleep he said he
used to try doing try making her laugh
when she was driving yeah yeah which
seems like you know not the wisest thing
to do but he apparently wasn't the
wisest child at least by his own
admission
well he was curious he was playing yeah
yeah yeah so so this is a very lovely
thing to know I think
and then the right
tail is one that enables people to play
along
but that's and that's a beautiful thing
it's like when I hang out with my my
friends like when we have those moments
together
that is what we're engaging in we're
engaging with this ball busting we're
engaging with this play and we're
engaging with these storytelling that
these stories always share something
about who one of us is or who we all are
you know oh blah blah blah uh loves big
girls remember when we were doing this
and he had that girl man she wasn't that
big blah blah and now it's like um
I'm not gonna make a parallel to the
Bible but like there's a reason why the
Bible didn't just say just do these
things there's a reason why they put
them in story right because it's far
more impactful to to listen to this
story and I wonder if like through
osmosis the behavior in the stories kind
of get locked into our long-term memory
where if you just tell someone a rule
it's short term and it might be fleeting
well the the thing about having the rule
embodied in the story is you see how
it's acted out
eh
so and then that's much more convincing
to watch how something's acted out
partly because then you also know how to
act it out right if it's just a rule you
have to translate the rule into action
but if it's a story then the actions are
laid out for you
you know and they say that every story
has a moral and in some sense that would
be the rule of the story
but it's not necessarily always that
easy to extract out the rule but you can
still understand the story
yeah yeah I'm really I want to do a deep
dive and like I just think I think one
of the issues with Hollywood right now
to be honest and like why some of these
films just don't make sense or so many
of them don't is because the the creator
of the idea is so far removed from the
executor of the project yeah so like hey
here's a great idea for a movie blah
blah blah and then someone goes I'm
gonna buy that from you that's great
thank you so much and then we're gonna
go make it and they're making with all
these people that are also kind of
detached from the project if you look at
the writer directors
their movies hit at a much higher rate
yeah it's not only because maybe they're
more talented but it's because they're
invested in the project all the way
through it means something if that
project fails because their identity is
wrapped into it a random person that
gets thrown on a project a random writer
that does punch-up that's not even
credit they also they also benefit from
the success so you know you were talking
about these censorship proclivities so
one of the things I observed in uh in
court in the corporate world when I was
attempting to sell to Middle managers
was that
if they bought something from me and it
failed they would get blamed
that would happen but if they bought
something for me and it was very
successful for the company they wouldn't
get credited
oh they wouldn't no because of this dis
because so I'll give you an example we
were selling these tests psychological
tests and uh to to a group of people who
were doing the hiring and they said well
they got budgeted on the cost side so
every cent they spend on hiring would be
um would be credited to them right as an
expense
but if they hired much better people and
the company did well that wouldn't be
credited to them as a as a uh
accomplishment because the the the value
would go to someone else it wouldn't be
directly attributed to them and so what
happened to them was that there was an
outside risk to each of them for acting
in an entrepreneurial manner
and very little upside if it was
successful and you can imagine in a
Hollywood production for example that
isn't spearheaded by a writer director
if it's successful he's going to be
wildly successful now he has to shoulder
the blame too but if it's distributed
among a bunch of people then they're
going to get blamed if something goes
wrong but if it goes real well they're
not going to get credited
exactly yeah yeah so and that's how you
have a shitty project maybe you get
lucky and it ends up working out but but
yeah I think that I like shouldering
that blame I'll take the risk on myself
with these projects like that I that I
want to do like I don't mind that if it
fails it's on me I can take that that
that's motivating that's exciting
you know and I also believe in myself
and the people that I work with that we
can execute these things so
but it's it's what happens is if you do
the if you run a business like that you
create a bottleneck you know like I I I
even went through this when I was
editing the special and we were editing
the special you know I edit it with uh
Mark and uh and Shifty who are
absolutely brilliant and we sat in there
and we edited it took us one day for
each minute of the special
hmm so for one 60 seconds it took us a
day of editing and we did that for until
it was done now nobody's edited a comedy
special like this but he's usually the
editors so far removed from the comic or
it's already with another production
company or it's already at one of these
streaming things but for me in order for
it to be as good and as nuanced and as
beautiful as it is in order for me to
take you into the room we need to edit
it that way like we were watching horror
movies
to see how they built tension and then
released it yeah because that's comedy
it's tension release so if you have slow
pushes while you're building the tension
and then uh removal when it's released
or like you zoom out when it's really
it's like okay let's use that let's
apply that how can we make you feel the
tension that you won't feel because
you're watching it through a screen how
can we bring you into the room you know
so so that's interesting so did you
focus in while you were building the
tension and then snap out
yeah well why did you decide that's very
interesting because that actually that
actually corresponds to different
hemispheric function
so the left hemisphere Zooms in and the
right hemisphere zooms out and that the
right hemisphere is responsible for
insight and the left hemisphere for
detailed processing and so you seem to
have you seem to have intuited something
like that in that editing process that's
very cool so you zoom in and then when
the punch line hits you can you can snap
to a broader perspective
will often hit a punch line on a zoom in
but sometimes a punch line is a
misdirection and by zooming in
immediately we would be telegraphing it
so what we would do is leave it in let's
say a cowboy shot or something like this
so we could catch you off guard because
catching you off guard is very important
right but maybe on a big laugh we let
the room breathe we were able to show
the audience laughing as well I think
there's a communal aspect when you're at
a comedy club you see other people
laughing and that's beautiful it's
cathartic you're like okay I'm free I
can let loose here so we want to we want
to show shots where other people are
laughing so you felt comfortable you
could get caught up in that momentum so
it's like approaching the editing
process with the same passion love and
creativity that we approached writing
the jokes and creating the show yeah
well that definitely definitely one of
the things that stand-up comedians are
doing is providing a communal theater
for free play
and it's definitely free because you
can't compel someone to laugh you can't
even compel yourself to laugh not
genuinely it has to be it has to come
from the source right it either strikes
you as funny before you think or it's
not funny at all and there is something
I think extremely
stress relieving to be among a lot of
other people who are laughing at the
same thing because it means you're all
being you're all playing spontaneously
together without fear and that's that's
almost like the definition of no stress
exactly and one of the things that we
like specifically did like like I would
say that my audience is by far the most
diverse audience in in stand-up now the
advantage of that is and one of the
things that I learned is I was going
through stand up and I like to make fun
of everybody because I'm curious about
everybody and I learned these things
about people that I think are like
really funny so when I organize them
into jokes I also like to talk about it
doesn't only have to be like me I'm not
very self-centered with my comedy which
is not necessarily a bad thing but I'd
like talking about topics other people
cultures Etc these things are all
interesting to me
um but what I realized is we were going
through this very like woke time where a
white dude a straight white dude like me
making fun of you know somebody from
Ethiopia might be crazy right but what I
realized is if that Ethiopian person was
there and I'm talking to them and doing
the joke to them and they're laughing
nobody can be offended yeah yeah right
Peterson does that very well eh I mean
brilliantly he's great brilliant man
because he he's an equal opportunity
offender and his uh and it's so
interesting to watch his audiences
because you can just you can almost feel
the tension in the different ethnic
groups in the audience waiting for their
chance to be made fun of and it's they
want it well yeah it's because I think
at a deep level they want to show that
they can play along with the joke you
know the two things they want to play
along and they want to show the game but
they also like representation in a
creative clever way yeah so like this is
something I learned without realizing
but like I would do these Joe folks
about random random groups right that
just you know knowledge I picked up over
the years and then because the internet
exists in these Echo Chambers those
jokes will go viral in those communities
right right right so the Bosnian
Community would hear about a joke I did
about some bosnians in St Louis there's
a big Bosnia Community there but it
would go crazy viral not only here but
in the Bosnian communities but in like
Bosnia and the beauty of this is
they felt represented not in a hacky way
they felt represented in a cool way they
didn't know that people knew this about
them they thought it was just their
community and then they're seeing it on
a YouTube page with millions of views
and the world is laughing at it as well
laughing is something they might be
proud of and they're cool with being
represented in that way yeah when you do
that the community wants to share it
they want to be part of it yeah
it's an invitation to the universal
table in some sense right it's it's a
place where everybody and that's what is
so wonderful about stand-up comedy it's
like a it's like a it's like a music
concert right it's the same sort of
thing is that people can go there and
and enjoy something spontaneously
communally and yeah play together and
I'm really happy by the way about this
insight about play you know I think if
you if you had to set the world up and
you wanted to figure out what the best
story you could possibly tell is that
would be an antidote to the the
depredations of power it does seem to me
that a story about play is the right one
because there's nothing more what are we
going to do this weekend what are we
going to do this weekend what are people
around the world going to do this
weekend
exactly they're going to play with death
they're going to play with the most
terrifying thing in the world yeah right
the most offensive costumes but also the
idea of death is which which spawn it we
need it it's and I Gotta Give Louis CK
credit on this like Louie had a uh he
was talking about comedy and it's like
making offensive jokes has existed for
centuries it would have been weeded out
if there wasn't something that we needed
if there wasn't some catharsis in it the
idea of Halloween like playing with
death is crazy if you really think about
it especially for earlier societies the
most terrifying thing in the world to
just
dabble with it and joke with it and
scare people we need it we want that
release we want that place well the
alternative the alternative is to run in
Terror from it and hide and all that
does the thing about that is all it does
is make it worse yeah and so I think
you know here's another way of thinking
about it so
when I was
training people who were agrophobic to
get back on elevators let's say
we basically did that by playing
and so the way it would work was all
right I'm afraid of this elevator I
can't get on this elevator I'll have a
panic attack my heart rate will go up to
150 Beats from per minute I think I'm
gonna die I'm gonna make a fool of
myself it's just I'm going to want to go
to the emergency room it's it's going to
be humiliating and dangerous it's just a
catastrophe it's death I had a client
who actually said when the elevator's
door is open she said that's a tube and
so she was she was afraid of dying in
there and so in a sense what we would do
is play because I would say well you
can't get on the elevator she said
that's right and I said well you know
can you look at a picture of an elevator
in a magazine it's like well I think I
could do that and so that's on the edge
of play right it's like well it's a bit
challenging and it's a bit threatening
but I could do it and then maybe you
have the person go out in the hallway
and you know they can walk within 40
feet of the elevator and so you find
that line it's a line right where the
person is willing to willing to walk up
to that line and then one step farther
and that's really again what you're
doing when you're telling a joke it's
you're finding that line and then you're
walking one step farther and and we
manifest that Spirit of play and it
helps expose people to the things they
don't want to think about
in a safe environment it exposes them in
a safe way yeah right because we all
know that we're playing it's just like
it's honestly it's like flirting you're
flirting with a girl are you flirting
with a guy flirting is finding that line
of what is polite and then being funny
enough to go a little bit past it and
now everybody's in that little naughty
territory yeah it's still safe because
we're playing it's not like you're
coming on too strong or like grabbing
people or anything like that you're
being naughty you're flirting you're
like yeah what if we were what if we
were married where would we go on
vacation and the girl's like what are
you talking about I just met you what do
you mean we're married and now we're
creating this hypothetical scenario
where we're both dancing the dance and
it's safe because it's play yeah we're
able well you know that says I think
that's also how women evaluate men while
they're dancing
is like well can you play right are you
all hands are you are you two you know
dead set on your instrumental goal or
can you control yourself well enough to
play and it's got to be to dance
properly is to be in that flirtatious
Zone exactly and that also indicates
that you're responding to the cues that
the other person is putting out there in
the most accurate possible way right now
you're going to be pushing slightly
because you want to find out where the
boundary is and that's probably what
makes it exciting but if you're just
rampaging in past all the boundaries
then you're just a dimwit yeah it may be
a dangerous one so and that's yeah and
that's the problem with politics is
there's no play it's boring it's binary
it's there's no fun whatsoever
everything that you say can get you
canceled for this or cancel with that
nobody's just allowing it to to just
play and I will give Trump Credit in
this regard yeah he was just up there
playing like he didn't give a [ __ ] he's
like I'm gonna make fun of this guy for
being short I'm gonna make fun of this
person for killing everybody I'm gonna
make fun of everybody on the stage and
people reacted to play they also reacted
to like you know him speaking on things
that their Fringe groups cared about but
there was an element of play yeah you
know I was given a book and
unfortunately I didn't keep it which was
a big mistake which was someone had
published quite a beautiful book it
looked like a kind of a leather-bound
library copy you know a a classic book
it was the collected poetry of Donald
Trump
and then what they had done was taken
his tweets and turned them into poems
page one page after page and I gotta
tell you man they were hilariously funny
it's funny it was unbelievably funny
he's unbelievably caustically witty yeah
and yep yeah yeah well and that was
certainly one of one of his Charming
features like
Megan Megan Kelly and Shout Out Megan I
love Megan but Megyn Kelly goes you've
called women pigs and you've called
women uh ogres or something like that
and he was like just Rosie O'Donnell
that's a funny playful thing to say on
the world stage you know calling uh
what's her face uh Pocahontas is funny
like it exposed politics in a lot of way
because if somebody's having fun that's
infectious especially if they're having
fun around everyone else who is not
you've been in these stuffy dinners I'm
sure they invite you all the time and
there is a table that's laughing and
goofing around and having it is
impossible not to look over at it it's
impossible not to see what's happening
where is this fun and why are you guys
having so much fun you enjoying
yourselves so so I have a theory of
leadership and you tell me what you
think about this so
imagine that all leaders are confronting
dragons of one sort or another
okay now the question is are you the man
for that Dragon because some of them are
large enough to burn you very rapidly to
a crisp
and so you might say well how do we
judge that how do we know if you're the
if you're the Knight for that particular
dragon and here's a good rule if you're
frightened into paralysis or tempted
towards tyranny in your attempts to deal
with the dragon which is this is so
catastrophic that I have to panic and
everyone has to listen to exactly what I
say then you're too small for the dragon
and you're not the right leader
and so I was thinking about this in
relationship to the climate crisis it's
like if the if carbon dioxide transforms
you into a paralyzed Tyrant you're not
the right man for the environmental job
and then you might say well who would
the right man be and that might be
someone who can approach that particular
dragon with a certain degree of play
and and what would that be so give give
me what what is the play how do we play
with the environment well I would say we
at least agree not to put in Rules by
compulsion
yes right so here's a rule no rules
instituted by compulsion because it's
bad play it's like you have to do this
it's like that's because that's a bad
policy
if you can't get me to go along with it
willingly then you're a tyrant and you
think the crisis is so important that
you get to be a tyrant but that just
shows that you're not a very good leader
yeah yeah don't you think I mean so yeah
you don't get to say you have to do this
not if you're not if you're a good
leader you have to say here's a bunch of
reasons you have to tell a story back to
what we were talking about earlier I
have to tell you a story and you think
yeah man I could get on board with that
I'm all in on that and that's a much
better Arrangement anyways because then
I don't have to enforce your compliance
you know you talked about these projects
that you were engaged in creatively if
you want them to work everybody's got to
be on board right if you're going around
hitting people to make them listen to
you then you're almost inevitably
dooming the project to failure because
first of all they're not going to be all
in and second they're going to take the
Revenge where they can get it
yes they have to believe in the project
as well they have to be pot committed as
well they have to believe in you
especially if you're their leader yeah I
mean the dragon the dragon metaphor you
can almost see day to day with like bull
fighting I know it's unfair because they
stab and wound the bull Etc but like he
he's not terrified of the bull running
away he's stared at the ball he's
dancing with the dragon yeah that's for
sure
exactly it's yeah with death it's the
same as Halloween man it's the same
thing to play with so why do we need
that maybe that's maybe that's how we
understand comedy maybe that's how we
understand Halloween maybe that's how we
understand like the darker sides of our
nature and people probably just want to
ignore them but maybe I can give you an
example of that so I was just on the Via
Dolorosa with Jonathan paggio who's a
Greek Orthodox Christian thinker who's
also an expert on post-modern Theory and
we went to Jerusalem we did a uh
documentary there which will be released
sometime in the next six months and we
walked the 12 Stations of the Cross in
Jerusalem and then we went to the Church
of the Holy Sepulcher which is founded
on the crucifixion spot and you might
say well what were we doing and what is
everybody doing who's walking that road
and the answer is they're playing with
tragedy and death
interesting that is that is what's
happening so you imagine that the
crucifix itself is a symbol of torturous
death
well why would people be gazing at it
and the answer is well because you have
to gaze upon that which frightens and
terrifies you because otherwise you
can't master it and so each of those
Stations of the Cross you know which are
marked out both mythologically and
geographically because it isn't certain
where each of those events occurred
let's say it's a it's a play it's a
passion play and the passion is look man
sometimes you're gonna have to die and
sometimes you're going to be exposed to
betrayal and sometimes you're going to
be under the thumb of a tyrant and
sometime you're going to be questioned
about Truth by a moral relativist and
and sometimes criminals are going to be
preferred to you that's all going to
happen to you in your life and you
bloody well better get ready for it and
the way you get ready for it is by
playing with it by playing with it you
bet yeah that's that's exactly what's
happening in those in those religious
rituals is it's play with death
yeah it's it's I mean I I was there as
well I you know you've got to touch the
stone and while I was you know the I was
at the uh not anointing Stone what is
the stone where where he where Jesus
body was wrapped up yeah you mean in the
in the whole in the Church of the Holy
Sepulcher yeah yeah right that's where
that's where he was wrapped after after
the crucifix yeah and it was a beautiful
moment and I saw people you know
touching it and I wanted to touch it but
I also was feeling naughty I was like
this is such this is such an important
place in history and I was wowed by the
fact that I could actually touch this
thing where like Jesus body was also
there but because of those high stakes I
was like oh what's the naughty thing
that we could do over here you know and
I think that that dance we have is why
theme parks exist like why are we on
roller coasters yeah you know we want to
face it that's why we go to horror
movies too which is really a very
difficult thing to understand and it is
it is you know this the the fundamentals
Spirit of religious affirmation I would
say is to is to play with catastrophe
fundamentally right and so and the
reason we have to play with catastrophe
is because we have to face catastrophe
and so there's all sorts of things we do
that appear very strangely like you said
amusement parks are a good example of
that because they they push you to the
limits of your physical tolerance and
they do it in a way that is constrained
danger and horror movies obviously do
that psychologically
yeah it's like sparring yeah you know
like sparring prepares you for fighting
in life but you do it in a more safe
environment yeah it allows you to be
more calm and comfortable in those
circumstances that happen in life that
are not going to be calm and comfortable
otherwise yeah yeah
that's all part of that Dragon
confrontation process is that you know
you want to find a dragon that's large
enough to pose some threat but that you
have a reasonable chance of overcoming
and then what you have is an optimal
challenge instead of something that
terrifies you and then you build the
challenges across time you know and
that's what you do as you become
competent
think think about you've seen the rise
in popularity of Jiu Jitsu right yeah
um and obviously we got to give our good
friend Joe Rogan credit for this MMA
credit for This Dana White but
Jiu Jitsu is the closest you can come to
death while training because if somebody
chokes you and you don't tap you just
die right you know what I'm saying like
in boxing you know you get knocked out
you get back up like it takes a lot of
brain trauma with like really small
gloves to be killed while you're
sparring I don't think you're getting
killed while you're sparring and boxing
you got the headgear the gloves are much
bigger but in Jiu Jitsu if someone just
keeps choking you and there isn't enough
oxygen that gets your brain you could
potentially die I could see why people
like playing with that yeah I could see
it it's fun well you know what you'll
find what you find in therapy it's very
very interesting there's a large body of
research supporting this so the idea
first of all was that if you expose
people to things they were afraid of and
you paired that with a relaxation
response they would learn to relax
instead of being afraid
but then it was rapidly discovered that
you didn't have to teach them to relax
and that kind of blew the whole Theory
because the theory was they had learned
to be afraid and now you were teaching
them to relax it's like nope all you
have to do is expose them voluntarily
and they get better and then the theory
was well they'll get better in
relationship to the specific thing
you're exposing them to but the symptoms
will just crop up somewhere else
yeah yeah but that also proved to be
wrong and it was because you know when
my client said this is a tomb when the
elevator doors opened what it showed was
she wasn't confronting the elevator
she was confronting her fear of death
and she really was doing that and what
she was learning was that by putting
herself in a position where she was
confronting the threat of death
she could observe that she could
actually handle it
and then she got braver and that's what
happens to people in Psychotherapy when
you use exposure therapy is they don't
become less afraid they become braver
and that generalizes and so what they
see is that there's something within
them that can overcome even the things
they're most afraid of and that's well
that's a good thing to talk about in
relationship to Halloween because I mean
Halloween plays with death and Decay and
predation and monstrosity and everything
that's dark and it's become an immense
holiday
and I think it is because our culture is
so sanitized that we take everything
that
smacks of death away and hide it and you
know to some degree thank God for that
yeah but it still presents us with this
conundrum which is well we have to face
the arfinitude and our mortality and how
best to do that and the answer has to be
something like
in a spirit of play God it's a hell of a
thing to think about when you're
thinking about death itself
but How brave of us today yeah well
that's exactly right man and I think
that's actually a good question right
How brave of us question mark and the
answer to that might be well How brave
can you be and God only knows how Brave
you can be maybe you can be brave enough
to play with death
and and this is why discourse has
completely Fallen apart because there's
no room to play yeah there's no room to
say the wrong thing there's no sparring
session there's no Halloween there's no
trying out the jokes trying out the
ideas it is death
it's not play yeah it's not even a
practice Yeah well that's the problem
with cancel culture you know well you
know I I learned years ago when I was
lecturing at Harvard I was talking about
very serious things about the Holocaust
and about the catastrophes and Soviet
Union and all of that absolute abysmal
hellish mess and there was a little
voice in the back of my head that said
you know you're too serious about this
if you really mastered it you could do
it in a spirit of play and I thought oh
my God you know really how can that
possibly be when discussing things that
seriously how could you possibly do that
in a spirit of play and the answer would
be something like Well if you really
mastered it
you could and that the Mastery would be
evident in the fact that you were
playing now that didn't really tell me
how right because it's still a big
problem of how you do that yeah but um
but I do believe it's true I believe
it's fundamentally true is that the
Mastery that someone
demonstrates over a given subject domain
is precisely proportionate to the degree
that they can do it in the spirit of
play
yes 100 yeah yeah how do you play with
these like dark these dark tricky topics
I think that was even with the Kanye
thing I think that was was so tricky is
like especially with the anti-Semitism
that was bubbling out yeah I think
anti-Semitism is this like it's such a
unique form of hate because one most
people are not familiar with juice
most people so if you're not familiar
with them
you haven't spoken to them and and
talked to them about how they react to
this and two the way that we get taught
like world history at least in America
is that like Germany was regular and
then all of a sudden one day they just
started hating Jews and then they were
putting them in concentration camps we
don't get taught what what Hitler used
and Goebbels use to build up the
resentment for the Jews that's not
really spoken about to us so I think a
lot of when the Jews hear these things
like they run the media they run the
banks it's red flag it goes uh oh this
is how it starts this is it's happening
and then when non-jews hear it they go
well those sound like some pretty cool
stereotypes I mean imagine imagine
someone like a black friend of mine who
wears glasses even that though he
doesn't have a prescription so people
think he's less threatening when he's
walking down the street imagine his
reaction to hearing The Stereotype own
the banks run the media own sports teams
he's going give me those stereotypes
right now because he's unfamiliar with
what those stereotypes lead to
so there's this huge Chasm with
understanding the hate of a group of
people and how those things which seem
complementary they seem [ __ ]
aspirational like you want to be able to
be in power positions but we because we
haven't been taught that those are the
things that first are said before you
dehumanize a group of people and then
kill six million of them
yeah well part of the problem with uh
with the with the discourse about about
the Jewish minority is the Jews are
disproportionately successful for all
sorts of reasons and so that that fact
easily feeds into conspiratorial
thinking right partly because minorities
are annoying you know but they're not
nearly as annoying when they're
unsuccessful
because at least they can what would you
call a tone for the sin of being a
minority by being oppressed and
miserable and so that's you know a
positive thing but if they're you're
saying
then they're really annoying it's
because not only are they a minority but
you know it's easy to become envious and
then it's also easy to presume that it's
some sort of conspiratorial uh practice
on the part of that Minority that's
giving them an advantage over you know
you who's striving ahead so nobly
you're giving a hypothetical to how the
majority sees minorities not how you see
minorities yes yes
[Music]
will have done the same thing I could
see a clip look minorities are annoying
but especially the the rich ones yeah I
mean yeah like yeah yeah you can be sure
The Young Turks are going to clip that
out
[Laughter]
but yes yeah I see yeah I know I just
see I saw it kind of happening in real
time and I'm planning to talk to him
soon I think
say again I'm planning to talk to Kanye
soon I think and and what are your what
are your thoughts about that have you
have you had
yeah what what is your thinking with
that well I'd like to find out what's
going on I mean he's a stunningly
creative person and he seems like a bit
too much of a treasure just to throw in
the dust bin
you know obviously he's got his problems
like most people do and the thing about
Geniuses is they have lots of problems
just like Ordinary People but they're
also geniuses
yes yes that's a good thing to keep in
mind
I think that Kanye's genius
outside of music I think he's an
incredibly gifted producer but I think
Kanye's genius is his ability to
influence and then the ability of then
the genius of influence
seeps into industries that are
completely subjective fashion
is nothing
Fastlane is if you can get the most
influential people to wear a garbage bag
that is cool now
things go in and out of style
skinny jeans are cool then baggy jeans
become cool yeah there's not a specific
cut that makes them good there's an edge
you know just just like the edge we were
talking about in comedy and fashion
comes imagine there's a social hierarchy
yep fashion goes from the top down it
even happens with names and so there's
there's a there's a standard trajectory
of names
the aristocracy picks names whatever the
aristocracy happens to be then those
names become popularized till everyone
has them then they go out of fashion and
then they disappear for a number of
generations and then the aristocracy
rediscovers them and the names Cascade
down the hierarchy again fashion is all
about being on the edge just like comedy
right is like are you with it are you
awake are you on The Cutting Edge and
that changes
exactly because and I I would say it
doesn't start at the top of the
aristocracy but I'm just you know we're
just pulling what is it I'm nitpicking
whatever but essentially fashion what is
cool is a rejection of what is popular
cool will always be the rejection of
popular right right so what happens is
the skinny jeans become ubiquitous and
then you start seeing them in the mall
stores yes and then there's a Target
there's a exactly target has them and
then there's a small group of like cool
kids that exists in a few different
areas that start rejecting the norm even
before they're in Target yeah those kids
once the thing is in Target because
they're such uh I don't want to say the
devil's Advocates or Counter Culture
whatever it is those kids are the wheel
influencers they get copied by a guy
like Kanye and then Kanye's influence
puts his clothing on a bunch of other
famous people who have influence and
then it trickles down to me other people
etc
those kids those kids the influence is
that you're talking about those are the
aristocracy among their age group
they're the creative kids that are on
the edge
no that's that's fair that's fair within
their peer group they're the coolest or
they're The Outsiders that nobody thinks
is no they're probably the coolest let's
say they're the coolest but yeah you
know is you've got it exactly right you
can be cool and an outsider at the same
time and that's a real artist right I
mean yeah yeah yeah yeah so all right
you know we should stop because we've
been going for well quite a long time
it's uh go go it's been a pleasure to
talk to you I should let everybody
watching and listening know that I'm
going to talk to Andrew for another half
an hour behind the daily wire plus
platform we're going to talk more
biographically I want to find out
exactly how he shaped his career
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com